diese bilder sind wirklich beeindruckend
die rede ist von den ersten aufnahmen
die das deutsche röntgenteleskop rosita
jetzt aus dem all zur erde gesendet hat
zu sehen ist unsere nachbargalaxien die
große magellansche wolke und außerdem
zwei wechsel wirkende galaxien hoffen
dass alles mit wirklich bemerkenswerte
details astronomie teams weltweit hoffen
jetzt mit hilfe von rosita endlich der
mysteriösen dunklen energie und der
dunklen materie auf die schliche zu
kommen
pixum science fiction hier gibt's
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts los
geht's herzlich willkommen im sommer
nämlich am 13 juli 2009 10 ist das
deutsche röntgenteleskop musiker ins all
gestartet das projekt gilt als das
wichtigste deutsche russische raumfahrt
projekt der täter soll nichts geringeres
tun als endlich das große rätsel um die
mysteriöse dunkle materie und die dunkle
energie zu lüften kurz gesagt trotz
intensiver forschung haben wir bislang
einfach keinen plan davon
woraus der größte teil des kosmos
eigentlich besteht und genau deswegen
soll das röntgenteleskop rosita in den
kommenden jahren den himmel durchmustern
und dabei fundamentale fragen des
universums beantworten jetzt also ein
vierteljahr nach dem start ins alle abo
sie da die ersten bilder aus dem alle an
die erde geschickt obwohl alle sieben
modulen des röntgen teleskops erst seit
mitte oktober 2009 10 den himmel
gleichzeitig im visier haben sind schon
die ersten aufnahmen wirklich
beeindruckend die röntgenbilder zeigen
nicht nur die so genannte große
magellansche wolke also unseren nachbar
galaxie auch zwei galaxienhaufen in
einer entfernung von etwa 800 millionen
lichtjahren sind zu erkennen
trotz dieser unvorstellbaren dimensionen
zeigen die bilder spannende details auch
das forschungsteam vom max planck
institut für extraterrestrische physik
mpe in garching ist überrascht von den
ergebnissen dazu der projektleiter peter
friedl jetzt ernten wir die früchte vor
mehr als zehn jahren arbeit will alle
sind beeindruckt von den wunderschönen
ersten bildern unseres teleskops konkret
zeigt die aufnahme der großen
magellanschen wolke wie sich das diffuse
heiße gas verteilt doch nicht nur das
auch die überreste von supernova
explosionen sind zu erkennen dass
astronomie team erkennt auf den bildern
dass sich die schockwelle der
sternexplosion die vor 32
also 1987 beobachtet werden konnte immer
weiter ausdehnt die quelle selbst also
die supernova mit der bezeichnung sn
1987 a wird dagegen schwächer rosita
zeigt aber auch die vordergrund sterne
unserer eigenen milchstraße und weit
entfernte aktive galaxienkerne das
röntgenteleskop hat die aufgabe vor
allem galaxienhaufen ins visier zu
nehmen und auch hier gibt es bereits
jetzt spannende ergebnisse die
beobachtung der rund 800 millionen
lichtjahre entfernten galaxienhaufen
gelangen mit den sieben musiker spiegel
modulen am siebzehnten und achtzehnten
oktober die bilder wurden mit hilfe
verschiedener analysetechniken
bearbeitet und dann eingefärbt so werden
die verschiedenen strukturen sichtbar
auf den aufnahmen der beiden
galaxienhaufen mit den bezeichnungen
a330 1 und a 3 395 schimmern diese grün
und sind durch blaue schlieren verbunden
sie erinnern an große nebel und
erstrecken sich über mehrere millionen
lichtjahre zudem enthalten sie tausende
galaxien die musiker offenbar damit zum
ersten mal dass diese beiden
galaxienhaufen miteinander agieren und
dynamische prozesse stattfinden zu
dieser premiere sagt peter praet das
macht erstmals sichtbar dass die
galaxienhaufen a 33 9 1 und a 3 395
dynamisch interagieren das hat man
bisher so noch nicht gesehen aber man
hat ihn die hoffnung es mit ingo sita
zeigen zu können doch das ist wohl nur
der anfang und das forschungsteam aus
garching ist sehr optimistisch dazu die
projekt wissenschaftlerin andrea meloni
ein traum ist wahr geworden wir wissen
jetzt dass sie da die erwartungen
erfüllen wird und eine karte des
gesamten röntgen himmels erstellen kann
so detailliert wie nie zuvor
neben so schönen bildern wie wir sie
heute zeigen werden die astronomen und
astronomen auf jahre hinaus unsere
kataloge nutzen um millionen von
exotischen objekten wie schwarze löcher
und galaxien neutronensterne supernovae
und aktive sterne zu analysieren
röntgenstrahlung macht hierbei die
strukturen des alls sichtbar deswegen
auch der name ingo sieht das steht für
röntgen survey telescope array bis zu
100.000 galaxienhaufen sollen in der
nächsten zeit beobachtet werden also
ansammlung von tausenden einzelnen
galaxien die durch die gravitation
miteinander verbunden sind möglich wird
deren analyse
durch das gas das sich in ihnen befindet
und bis zu 100 millionen grad heiß ist
wegen dieser hohen temperatur sendet es
röntgenstrahlung aus die fachleute
wollen durch die verteilung der
galaxienhaufen herausfinden wie sich das
universum ausdehnt wie es damals aussah
und natürlich auch wie es heute aussieht
bis zu 6 milliarden jahre soll die
musiker zurückblicken können und hier
kommt dann auch die dunkle energie ins
spiel eine mysteriöse kraft die das
universum auseinandertreibt und über die
expertinnen experten weltweit nur sehr
wenig wissen um das zu ändern müssten
zunächst verschiedene charakteristika
der galaxienhaufen bestimmt werden
daraus könnten dann im besten fall
rückschlüsse auf die dunkle energie
gezogen werden
dazu die astrophysikerin es wohl bull
ausgleichen
wenn wir die entwicklung der
galaxienhaufen über kosmische zeitskalen
hinweg verfolgen können wir die
kosmischen parameter präzise messen und
so die dunkle materie und dunkle energie
besser verstehen die das universum
dominieren eu sieht da könnte also eine
antwort auf die wohl faszinierendste
frage der astronomie und physik geben
und das wiederum könnte eine
fundamentale revolution der physik mit
sich bringen wie das mpe auf seiner
webseite schreibt doch dafür brauchen
wir wohl noch etwas geduld denn die
musiker hat sieben jahre zeit für diese
ganze arbeit dunkle energie
in diesem video erklärt doktor watson
wie immer umfassen worum es sich handeln
könnte also anklicken anschauen und auf
jeden fall doktor watson abonnieren
es lohnt sich bis dann bleibt dran